حسنًا ، هذا هو kinjal
أول واحد تم إطلاق النار عليه ،
هذا هو ، هاه ، هذا أه عملي ،
لقد تم تدميره فوق سرعة الصوت في التربة
kinjal ،
وسترى حسنًا ، لقد
حصلت عليه في الوسط ، فأنت تعرف نعم
في المنتصف نعم
جدًا  الطريق في الوسط نعم
هذا المكان حيث أه
صاروخ
معترض هذا صاروخ
أخبرني عن تلك الليلة
كيف كانت تلك الليلة عندما كنت
تنتظر
ثم تسمع kinjal قادمًا
إلى أوكرانيا في
تلك الليلة عندما اصطدم الروس بالصواريخ
الأسرع من الصوت  صاروخ كينزال
اكتشفناه على رادار باتريوت وكنا
نتابعه بعد أن تم
اعتراض الصاروخ وتدميره ، كان
اعتراضًا فعالًا للغاية ، حدث
سريعًا جدًا ، حيث نجح نظام باتريوت لأنني
أعتقد أنه أفضل
نظام صاروخي مضاد للطائرات ، فهو ليس نظامًا صاروخيًا.  مشكلة
كيف شعرت في تلك الليلة
كنت لا أعرف ما هي الكلمة الصحيحة ولكن
لا بد أنها كانت شديدة بشكل لا يصدق وربما
تشعر بالتوتر لمعرفة
ما إذا كان كل شيء سيعمل
ويمكنك إخراج صاروخ وهذا
الصاروخ هو  أسرع صاروخ لديهم على
حق أنه
يمكن تجهيزه برأس حربي نووي ، هل
يمكن أن أعني أن هذا هو أفضل ما
تملكه روسيا
بعد أن حصلنا على تأكيد بأنه كان
Kinsel الذي أسقطناه للتو أولاً وقبل
كل شيء كان شعورًا بالسعادة التي
شعرنا بها  فخورون وشعرنا بالارتياح لأنه من
خلال نظام باتريوت الخاص بنا يمكننا
اعتراض الصواريخ التي قيل لنا إنه
من المستحيل اعتراضها أخبرني عن
تدريبك أه
[تصفيق]
شهرين
وشهر واحد نحن نتدرب في أوروبا
أه إنه شيء
مثير جدًا  لقد
كان جزءًا من حياتنا تعليميًا مثيرًا للغاية مع الأخذ
في الاعتبار حقيقة أن
فريقنا يتمتع بخبرة كبيرة في العمل مع
أنظمة الصواريخ السوفيتية المضادة للطائرات ،
كان لدينا بعض المعرفة الأساسية وبفضل
مدربينا ذوي الخبرة ، تمكنا
من تعلم هذا  - نظام صاروخي للطائرات
سريع جدًا ، هذا هو معدات العصر الجديد ،
لذا من المستحيل
مقارنته بمعداتنا السوفيتية القديمة عندما
التقينا بميخائيل وفيلوديمير من الواضح أنني
رأيت وجوهك ولكن تتحدث الآن أنك
ترتدي بالاكلافا لتغطيتها
وأخبرني لماذا  هذا ليس
فقط أن الروس يريدون العثور على
صواريخ باتريوت واستهدافهم ، بل يريدون أيضًا
استهدافك ، كما أن
الموارد البشرية لفريقك مهمة جدًا
لأوكرانيا ، إنه جزء مهم جدًا
هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين ذهبوا إلى
الولايات المتحدة  تعلم هذا النظام ،
كان من تم اختيارهم الأفضل من بين
الأفضل ، إنه مورد مهم للغاية
ما أحاول قوله هو أنه ليس فقط
النظام مهمًا ولكن أيضًا الأشخاص
الذين يعرفون كيفية تشغيله وهذا هو السبب في أننا
غطينا وجوهنا  لذلك لن يتم
التعرف علينا لا
نريد منح الروس أي
فرصة لمعرفة مكان نظامنا